-We are about to play charades.
But, first,
we're gonna need some players.
Joining my team, she's a
hugely successful entrepreneur
who just launched her
new website, martha.com.
Please welcome Martha Stewart!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hi.
-Our first competitor is one of
the funniest people out there.
His stand-up special
"Shame the Devil,"
premieres November 16th
on Netflix.
Please welcome Michael Che!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Martha.
-Hi.
-Hello, James.
-Good to see you, buddy.
Joining Michael's team,
he's one of the biggest
musicians in the world.
His new album,
"=", is out now.
Number 1 everywhere.
Please welcome Ed Sheeran!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Look at this.
This is -- Look at --
Come on. Look at --
This is a grouping.
Alright, now, we all know
how to play charades.
We're gonna do four rounds.
30 seconds on the clock
per round.
Then the fifth round is
the showdown.
Both teams get the same clue
at the same time.
I will go first.
You guys can all
take your seats.
Michael -- No, Martha,
you're over here.
-Over here?
-Yeah, we're Team Fallon.
Yeah. Here we go.
Alright, good.
Alright, this is gonna be --
Alright, what number
shall I choose, guys?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Everyone just said 4.
Alright. Interesting.
Mm-hmm.
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
Alright, you ready for this?
-TV.
-Mm-hmm.
-Show.
Three words.
-Mm-hmm.
-Word number one.
Salute.
Army?
Flag.
Armed services.
I'm terrible at this.
Or maybe you're terrible
at this.
-No. No, Martha...
-Second word.
-Can we guess?
-No, you can't guess, Ed!
No. Alright.
-You sure it's not --
[ Buzzer ]
-Why?! What?!
I'm sorry.
Second one, you would have --
The second one
would have gotten it.
I should have done
the second word.
-"Karate Kid"?
No.
-Yeah.
-What is it?
-"American Ninja Warrior."
-Oh!
-What?
[ Laughter ]
"American Ninja Warrior"?
-"American Ninja Warrior."
Yeah, it's a --
-Oh, God.
-Alright, Ed...
-I'm up?
-Yeah, Ed.
Why don't you give it a shot.
-Oh, yeah. Let's do this.
-Audience, what number?
What do you think?
-This is what I'm talking about.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Come on, Ed.
Lucky number 7.
You got it.
-Okay.
What's song? What's song?
What's song?
Okay.
-Song!
[ Laughter ]
-No, that's not the clue.
No, yeah, it's a song.
-That wasn't the clue.
That wasn't the clue.
-Alright. What else you got?
Song. Yeah, I got you.
Oh!
"Harlem Shake."
-No, no.
-"Thriller."
It's not the "Harlem Shake"?
-That's one --
-How many words?
-Three --
Oh, "Harlem Shake Remix."
"Get the Dirt Off
Your Shoulder."
-No, no.
-"Lean Wit It, Rock Wit It."
-What word --
what word are you doing?
That was the first word --
-"To the left, to the left"?
[ Buzzer, cymbal crash ]
-"Shake It Off"?
-"Shake It Off"!
-It had "Shake."
-I was gonna say,
you could have taken it off.
-No, Martha, it's not
"Take It Off."
"Shake It Off."
-Oh.
-"Shake It Off."
-Alright, here we go.
Alright.
One of us has to get 1 point.
Martha, you're up. Please.
-Oh, geez.
-We got this. Come on, buddy.
-It must be the worst.
-Come on. We're good partners.
We're good at this.
-Oh, this is very easy.
-Okay.
-I love the confidence.
-Yeah.
-Look at this.
Yeah, movie.
How many words?
Oh, ooh, ooh!
You're walking on a tight rope.
You're walking on a tight -- No.
It is a line -- It is a --
No, no. It's one word?
Zipline?
No -- Yeah.
One word, three syllables.
-Time's got to be up.
-Tightrope.
Oh, no. I can't get it.
-Oh, I know it.
I know it.
-Wait. You know it, too?
-Yeah, I know it. We know it.
-You're walking on the --
balancing.
Oh.
-Oh!
-"Walk the Line"!
-Yeah!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Man!
Man, man, man!
-Even I knew that one.
Even I knew that one.
-Something just popped
in my brain.
I just -- I was like --
I felt it. Wow!
That was -- I broke a sweat.
-Alright, alright.
I'm ready. I'm ready.
-Alright, Mike.
-Okay, 1 point.
-Michael Che.
-We got a point.
-Yeah, we got a point.
This is great!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
[ Laughs ]
Okay.
Alright, alright,
alright, alright.
Oh, man! Alright.
Alright, alright.
Alright, ready?
-Ed's got this.
-Film.
It's four words.
Small?
No.
Hat.
-Mnh-mnh.
No.
No. Small no.
-Second word.
Time.
Dead.
-Oh, yeah. You know this.
-"No Time to Die."
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow! Wow!
-"No Time to Die."
-It's a barn burner!
-It's a giant movie.
-It is a barn burner!
Alright, this is the last one.
Both people giving --
will give the same clue,
and the first one to guess
wins the whole thing.
But we get to select
who is giving the clues.
-Ooh! What do you want to do?
-I don't know.
Well, I think we'll go with
what we know, I think.
We won that one.
-Alright, I'm in.
I'll do it again.
Come on, let's do it.
-"SNL" buds.
-Yeah, let's do it.
Which one we picking?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
I saw 88.
[ Laughter ]
-5?
-Alright.
Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
-You good?
-Alright, alright. Alright.
Let's do it, let's do it.
Come on. We're gonna do it.
We're gonna do it.
Hey, hey...
-Alright, ready, Martha?
Ready?
-Yeah, you ready?
-Ready? Here we go.
-Film.
-"Dirty Dancing"?
[ Dinging ]
Yeah?
Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Come on!
-They got it?
-That's what I'm talking about.
That's what I'm talking about.
-I only just watched that flick.
I got a poster for my wife for
Christmas of all the best films,
and we scratch them off.
And I'd never seen it, and we
watched it like last week.
-What did you say?
-"Dirty Dancing."
-I said "Dirty Dancing," but you
didn't hear me.
-Yeah.
-I said it before you said it.
-Have to enunciate.
-I said it right away.
I said "Dirty Dancing."
-Oh, my goodness!
We'll come back.
We'll talk with the judges.
My thanks to Michael Che,
Martha Stewart, Ed Sheeran.